today we'll discuss vesicular liquid
biopsies for pregnancies which can be
used as a non-invasive monitoring system
for the quality of pregnancies
throughout the pregnancy
I want to start with a review of The
Clinical and scientific approach to give
you an idea as to why we would use this
approach in the context the pregnancy
pre-term labor and preeclampsia comprise
two of the so-called great obstetric
diseases though the clinical
presentation of preeclampsia is distinct
from preterm labor and should not be
confused clinically with it It is
believed that these two great diseases
may share common pathogenic mechanisms
mechanisms which may arise secondary to
aberrant placentation during the first
trimester of pregnancy
cytotrophoblast normally invade the
decidua of the uterine lining to
transform the uterine wall and lining
during
placentation the arrangements in
vascular Remodeling and other
transformations in the first trimester
may present a root cause for for both
preterm labor and preeclampsia
all set up by the end of the first
trimester
placenta creda is yet another serious
condition for pregnancy
whereby the placenta grows too deeply
into the uterine wall all three
conditions May benefit from early
minimally invasive methods to detect
pathogenic mechanisms affecting the
Maternal Fetal interphase this enables
early interventions Say by 16 weeks that
could reduce severe outcomes to both the
baby and the mother
Nano and micro vesicles also called
exosomes or micro particles are a
regulated form of information Exchange
they provide another means for our cells
and tissues to respond to physiological
stimuli or disease
they relay that response locally or at a
distance
and they deliver biological payloads to
cells and tissues
these little guys are not rare in fact
they are surprisingly abundant to the
tune of billions or trillions per
milliliters
by some estimates and they carry a rich
source of biological content exciting
stuff for biologists and diagnosticians
again the truly important point for this
talk is that they are biologically
active and for this conference group
they Harbor a rich source of proteins
especially interesting is the cellular
content which allows us to assess cell
signaling and other such interesting
phenomenon
during pregnancy the placenta and
Maternal Fetal compartment May
contribute contribute at least half the
number of circulating exosomes while
sampling the womb and its environs
the exosomal MP content will
additionally be sampling systemically
providing information about the mother's
current condition
and reaction to the pregnancy
monitoring the pregnancy non-invasively
is our goal and we particularly want to
do this early in the pregnancy in the
first trimester an effective liquid
sampling or biopsy avoids needles and
villus or placental sampling and the
attendant dangers of that
I'll now
discuss the basic technology and give an
assay overview
of how we collect the data and do the
analysis that I'll be showing you later
in the talk
the platform we are using for particle
analysis is based on two steps for one
of them I am lumping together several
sub steps as you'll see
initially there's the exosome
microparticle isolation step
and then there's a mass spec proteomics
analysis step
the overall workflow as seen here is
really not unlike
uh conceptually speaking a typical
genetic testing or next-gen sequencing
workflow start again
in both cases you have an isolation step
of the content to be analyzed a
preparation step for analysis and an
analyzer for that content and then the
informatics software step and and
interpretation and a report generated
specifically for what we do we use
custom-made columns from a GMP
manufacturer in Massachusetts for
isolation
a patent-pending method for prepping the
proteins for analysis
we use a targeted mrm approach to
quantify the established markers for
preterm birth
an algorithm is used to score the values
for risk stratification
The nexozone Columns we use for
isolation are a modified size exclusion
chromatography column with some bead
specializations and a proprietary buffer
to optimize particle enrichment and
yields
about a half of a milliliter of blood is
used in the current configuration
seen here we have a red graph with
Optical measurements
under the modified SEC graph
and
that tells us where the vesicles are
that is overlaid onto a protein
concentration measurement
which can be seen to the right
there are 24 fractions collected now
that's more than we usually collect for
a clinical assay but we do this for QA
the two peaks indicate where the Nano
microparticles are and where the plasma
proteins are
and that is the second p p to the right
that indicates the plasma proteins
the shoulder
next to the peak that second Peak
represents the particle protein
which of course overlaps the particle
fractions indicated by the red Peak
we have
on the right proprietary dark field
hyperspectral Imaging methods to
visualize Nature's Beats and software to
size and quantify them so what you're
seeing is a mass of microparticles and
nanoparticles mainly exosomes and
mid-sized vesicles spread out over a
slide this came from one of the
fractions
that next panel on the right just
indicates the software which can size
and count these micro vesicles and
exosomes so that we can identify and
quantify them
the mass spectrometry protein prep step
includes patented online cleanup that
avoids multiple purification and
enrichment steps offline
there is minimal sample loss this way
and we don't have to remove membranes
lipids nucleic acids small molecules and
that sort of stuff we get higher
resolution about 10-fold signal
intensification shorter run times and
other benefits by using our particular
setup
and there's there are patent-pending
methods associated with this
the analyzer used is the tsq Altus MD
and the main point I want to make here
is that we use what's called normaflow
by the Vanquish uhplc
rather than nanofluidics which would
take a very long time per sample this
gives us run times of 10 minutes or less
that are comparable to other run times
for clinical assays such as Vitamin D
measurements and toxicology
the mega enrichment we get with the
columns allows us to do this
and the CVS are very good over the
entire process that is from collection
all the way through analysis as you can
see over on the right generally in about
the plus minus 10 percent range
we worked very closely with Dr Zen Zhang
from Johns Hopkins he's an excellent
bioinformaticist and by statistician
he used several AI methods and rigorous
statistics to build our classification
models
this allowed us to stratify patients as
high or low risk and we now can issue a
risk-based score
lab report that's indicated on the right
I'll talk more about the details of the
data specifically the second panel to
the right in just a moment
I just want to point out with this slide
that we collaborated with Therma Fisher
and its brims on the pre-eclampsia
project I'll talk about later in the
talk
we did the particle isolations ourselves
and then sent them
those isolates they did the MS Discovery
work analytically
Tom McGill wrath Dr mcelroath from the
Brigham did the informatics and
classification work and we had some
input from Dr Zhang
I now want to move on to a review of the
actual clinical data that was derived
from those methods
the preterm birth study followed a
systematic Discovery qualification
verification and validation scheme
I'll tell you more about the extended
validation we're undergoing in a moment
validation
that you see here the third paper from
2019 was a multi-site validation
and all those blood samples came from
similar collection protocols and all
were from the first trimester about 10
to 12 weeks
in addition to an all moms panel
we whittled down from a larger Discovery
set to a four marker panel for the
validation studies shown here those
markers are ic1 lcat trfe and itih4
those markers correlated with known
Pathways in the pathophysiology for
preterm birth including oxidative stress
adaptive innate immunity trophoblastic
function and placentation mechanisms
that panel classifies specifically
first-time mothers which are an
important unmet clinical need
because there are known no known markers
for that subgroup and I can
get to that in a moment
Roc curve to the right indicates the
performance of the panel the new mom
panel and the algorithm performance for
new moms versus all moms the new mom Roc
as indicated in red
we have a second panel that's useful for
all mothers regardless of parity that is
whether the mother had a baby previously
Kaplan Meyer curved to the left
illustrates two populations separated
out by gestational age at Birth using
the risk stratification model
the red indicates that low-risk verbs
and the blue line indicates the high
risk Birds
the model works pretty well especially
considering that these are asymptomatic
patients in the first trimester with an
event that occurs or doesn't many months
later
in fact the performance of our model
is quite better than current assays
indicated here
including clinical parameters and
biophysical approaches that predict or
diagnose preterm birth
and uh versus turnbirds the extended
validation we are currently involved in
is the largest of its kind
using a government-funded biobank that
was almost tailor-made for our panel and
validation studies the so-called new
mom-to-d cohort
Pi being Dr David Haas at Indiana
University
um it was another academic collaborator
um
almost 10 000 first-time moms were
participants with an extensive data
collection and multiple sample types
collected at defined intervals
throughout the pregnancy
the NIH randomly selected about 2400 of
the participants
the breakdown of normal versus disease
or birth complications is shown here
we have broken up the validation into
three phases and we have recently
completed the data generation for the
first and second phases data analysis is
ongoing
all I can say right now with this slide
which is very preliminary is that using
the same algorithmic model from the 2019
paper which we call study e
using that model we recapitulated the
results
when looking at the early data from this
new cohort
that model stratifies risk for early
births especially very early births in
this new cohort
the development path for Homebrew lab
develop test is shown here
it shows where we've been documented and
published
who are Partners were both public and
private that are critical to Our Success
where we are going to release our first
generation test
which may be within the next six to 12
months
okay this slide is just a reminder to
reintroduce the preeclampsia
collaborative study between
NX prenatal Brigham and Women's and
Therma Fisher
the pretty eclampsia study involved
David saracino in the brims
we use the same nexozone isolation
protocol
for particle isolation from a first
trimester preeclampsia cohort
I sent those samples and he fed those
into a Vanquish uhplc coupled to a
fusion lumos
Dr Miguel Ross at bwh performed the
statistical analyzes on about 800 to 900
protein candidates identified by first
creating libraries
and then performing the comparative
proteomics and using the libraries to
confirm IDs the takeaways from the study
are first of all a clinically relevant
set of markers that can stratify
patients for preeclampsia specifically
preeclampsia before 35 weeks
more interestingly
these markers can stratify for more
severe clinical presentations for
example the mean blood pressures are
higher in
cluster group two
and that group also has higher 24-hour
urine protein values both of these are
classic definitions of preeclampsia
cluster one was associated with a less
severe phenotype and a platelet-centric
biological pathway mechanistic structure
cluster 2 was identified with a
complement Centric biological pathway
annotation both of these clusters make
sense clinically and they both suggest
specific Therapies
a further demonstration of the
generalizability of the approach is the
most recent collaboration between NX
prenatal Brigham and Women's
the Beijing genome Institute with
support from Thermo Fisher
the placenta accreta study
as I said earlier this involves a
placental encroachment deeper into the
uterine smooth muscle wall
the outcomes of such a disease have
potentially severe consequences
including massive Hemorrhage unintended
hysterectomies and death we worked our
nexusome isolations into the bgi
workflow which involved both their data
independent and data dependent
acquisition processes
the idea was to create accreta versus
normal libraries and use those for IDs
during the profiling of the particulate
samples
this data just hit us a few weeks back
so I'm not really going to show you
classification data which is ongoing but
what I will show you here is the type of
information you can get from these
little vesicle buggers and the
biological and basic insights possible
first the hits the proteins themselves
and the pathways you get are often
cellular very relevant
um of a signaling and metabolic pathway
nature
they are not few
many very interesting pathways are seen
such as those in cancer
development and invasion of metastasis
pathways
this is not Irrelevant for trophoblastic
disease of an invasive phenotype
see this is like getting a cellular and
tissue biopsy of protein content but you
get this peripherally
what I'm showing you here is a very
interesting example
um of a signaling circuit diagram that
was hit multiple times
different proteins
I have intentionally de-highlighted
important hits in the smooth muscle
contraction pathway
um
which is actually relevant to both
vascular and uterine smooth muscle
contraction
vascular development and regulation is
highly important to both placental
development and partition or birth
and just tell you that the key signaling
Regulators include G proteins kinases
activators of kinases myofilament
Regulation and several new objects of
interest and I can tell you we'll have a
lot of fun analyzing that data
foreign
so as an overall summary to wrap up
I'd like to point out that we have a
distinct early warning system that
follows a logical progression of
monitoring prenatal care
we are sampling important biological
processes and the crosstalk between the
mother and the child
as well as systemic information and the
reactions to the Maternal Fetal
environment by the mother
a non or minimally invasive biopsy
technique depending on the sampling of
micro and Nano vesicular content will be
very useful for this strategy
thank you